las fotos expuestos en la alcaldía de
kant transportan al visitante a uno de
los momentos más impactantes de los
últimos tiempos es un retrato íntimo del
sufrimiento humano en el corazón de los
ataques del 11 de septiembre
queríamos incluir imágenes simbólicas
para que quedara claro de qué se trataba
la exposición pero sobre todo queríamos
centrarnos en los rostros la mirada de
quienes ven las torres gemelas ahí es
donde se ve el terrible trauma por el
que pasaron los neoyorquinos la muestra
fue organizada bajo la atenta mirada del
veterano fotógrafo de guerra patrick
sobel aquí puedes ver esta foto de un
hombre definitivamente no fue un día
para dejar de fumar te golpeó una
especie de soledad acaba de salir de la
torre todavía está cubierto de polvo
nosotros en la foto no están cubiertos
de polvo por lo que no estaban allí lo
que ha vivido es tan impactante que no
se puede comunicar
la exposición también rinde homenaje a
los héroes del 11 de septiembre para el
alcalde de kaun hay ecos del pasado de
su ciudad
tepic anotó desde hace algún tiempo
sentimos que tenemos la responsabilidad
de transmitir un mensaje universal en
defensa de los derechos humanos y la paz
queremos explicar a que pueden conducir
los peores errores de la humanidad
expliqué el suda cuado mutis efectivo
hasta donde seguramente el tema continúe
en una segunda exhibición organizada en
el museo conmemorativo de khan que
muestra las consecuencias geopolíticas
que trajo el 11 de septiembre por
defender su acera dic tomamos decisiones
bastante radicales centrándose
principalmente en cinco o seis
fotógrafos mostrando también el trabajo
de cineastas la exposición que cuenta
con trabajos de reporteros gráficos como
tim hetherington o bullet kilic estará
abierta al público hasta finales de año